[Music]
what can i get for you
something hot cold coffee liquor
pass on the coffee i'll uh have a spunky
monkey instead
everyone listen up this is a [ __ ]
robbery
mr slick behind the counter yeah you
shut the [ __ ] up put your hands up where
i can see him
rest of you stay where you are and don't
[ __ ] move a muscle if i hear so much
as a peep
you're only getting a sidearm overland
we clear
while it's on the table somebody likes
being the center of attention
what part of keeping your [ __ ] mouth
shut did you not understand
how about you go first hand over your
wallet
nice and easy
can't believe you've made it this far
people who don't judge their competition
don't last too long on the streets
i've met people like you before they're
all dead now
know why because none of them could get
the speck on me
nice try you're bluffing trying to trip
me out dance of maelstrom and arisaka
you think you could so much as scratch
me
you'll die before you can pull that
trigger i guarantee
you [ __ ] it let's bail
for years nobody touches this place and
now this where's 6th street when you
need them
thank god you are here order whatever
you want it's on the house
for a chance to win a one-week getaway
for two
at the crystal palace
five poles top-end brain dance